muchas gracias a mares por la
presentación de verdad para mí es un
placer estar acá la iniciativa y todo el
proyecto en sí me parece fantástico
muchas gracias por hacerme parte de esto
creo que es tiempo de concientizar y
actividades como esta pues reflejan esa
necesidad de ser humano en estos
momentos
pero también creo fielmente de que
tenemos que ser agentes de acción
agentes de cambio aunque sea pequeño muy
pequeño pero puede ser muy significativo
desde lo que están viviendo aquí con los
talleres y las exposiciones y llevarlas
a la vida real a su día a día para que
realmente existan cambios más adelante
yo le tengo mucho peso y eso quería
compartir el vídeo con ustedes ya que me
están dando ese espacio tan bello y tan
bonito a través de la música y
precisamente es con la música y en
homenaje también un poco a nuestra
tierra que vengo presentarles la
siguiente canción se llama baila van a
escuchar en algunas partes de la letra
que hace como mención de homenaje a las
montañas en la tierra que nos da tanta
vida nos quiere solamente nos pide que
la cuidemos con ese mensaje con esa
fuerza llega baila para acompañar ese
momento espero que lo disfruten lo dice
así
i
de las montañas
las montañas se mueven se mueven al
ritmo del sol golpe de nuestro cajón de
se mueven al ritmo del sol el golpe de
nuestro carro
y para el más solventes cables y palmas
y nadie nos va a detener y haremos hasta
amanecer y nadie nos va a detener
bailaremos hasta amanecer en amores
[Música]
pues está llena de amor amor
antes de que se vaya
y
vamos a hablar
[Música]
eres morena desde miedoso atrás
y tu corazón el amor
[Música]
deja que el amor
d
[Música]
quizá que sea moreno
por qué
y no es así
[Música]
y deja que éste vaya
no
y
y dije que no
[Música]
y deja que se vaya moreno
eso fue baila muchas gracias por este
espacio de verdad muchas gracias
nuevamente por la invitación bailes una
canción
que busca transmitir eso energía
y que a través de la danza y del arte
podemos también encontrar mucha
fortaleza
yo estoy muy contenta de verdad de ver
esa acá quiero agradecer también a ted
ex de la universidad nacional mayor de
san marcos por esta hermosa invitación y
este espacio y todo lo que están
haciendo aquí lo que han venido
realizando es admirable y felicitaciones
por eso que vengan muchas más
actividades y sigan pasándola muy bien
aquí yo me despido soy nice ya he estado
muy feliz de compartir con ustedes nos
vemos pronto chao